-Performing
"Hiding Out in the Open"
from her album "Multitudes,"
please welcome Feist!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Everybody's got their share ♪
♪ But who's got the guts
to sit with it? ♪
♪♪
♪ Everybody's on their own ♪
♪ So, that way,
we're never alone ♪
-♪ We're never alone ♪
-♪ But the mirror
in another's eyes ♪
♪ That'll get you every time ♪
♪ There are a thousand
different ways to hide ♪
♪♪
♪ Hiding out in the open ♪
♪ Maybe I'm gonna let you down ♪
♪ Nothing's gonna make us new ♪
♪ What's done
is not gonna undo ♪
♪ Hiding out in the open ♪
♪ Baby, he's gonna let me down ♪
♪ Love is not a thing
you try to do ♪
♪ It wants to be the thing
compelling you ♪
♪ So what we should
probably say ♪
-♪ Should probably say ♪
-♪ Let's put off
for a few more days ♪
-♪ For a few more days ♪
-♪ And, anyway,
I'll pretend not to hear ♪
♪ Till you whisper it
in my ear ♪
♪ Ooh, ohh,
hot voice on my neck ♪
♪ Would change the context ♪
♪ I want you warm
as a loaf of bread ♪
♪ Thousand ways to be fed ♪
♪♪
♪ Hiding out in the open ♪
♪ Baby, I'm gonna let you down ♪
♪ Nothing's gonna make us new ♪
♪ What's done
is not gonna undo ♪
♪ Hiding out in the open ♪
♪ Baby, he's gonna let me down ♪
♪ Love is not a thing
you try to do ♪
♪ It wants to be the thing
compelling you ♪
♪♪
♪ To ♪
♪ Be you ♪
♪♪
♪ Ohh, love is not a thing
you try to do ♪
♪ It wants to be the thing
compelling you ♪
♪ To ♪
♪ Be ♪
♪ You ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]